viel viel
hey leute und willkommen zu einer neuen
mode review heute von dem motto time
control remote mod heißt glaube ich und
zwar ist es mit diesem motto ganz
einfach möglich dass euer minecraft
langsamer läuft als ob man alle sich
langsamer bewegt nicht nur ihr sondern
auch die ganzen tiere eure bewegungen
zum beispiel wenn den shader drin hab
das gras bewegt sich langsamer das
wasser fließt langsamer oder halt auch
dass alles schneller läuft und ich habe
hier schon in diesen vier kästen hier
diese ganzen sachen die es da gibt da
gibt es den time control remote diese
uhr sage ich mal dann gibt es fest
motion remote slow motion remote und
matrix remote matrix remote würde jetzt
letztens neu hinzugefügt also eine ganz
frische motto you und dem ort deshalb
komplett neu in dem forum auch na ja
jedenfalls zeige ich euch mal ganz kurz
wir die sachen kraft erst mal diese
grundvoraussetzungen mache ich mir mal
gleich drei von weil man die noch neben
hat mich nochmal vier so da macht ihr
einfach da oben also nord süd west ost
macht ihr gold hin dann in dieser
anderen verbleibenden ecken diamanten
und in die mitte schalter so dann
bekommt ihr diese time control remote
teile davon haben wir jetzt hier
irgendjemand zu viel davon haben wir
jetzt 44 jetzt sind wir den schneeball
tut er halt auch diese ganzen decken was
und dann in die mitte mit dem time
control remote dann kriegt ihr einen
slow motion remote dann macht ihr das
gleiche nochmal mit zucker anstatt den
schneebällen dann bekommt ihr den fest
motion links und dann das gleiche
nochmal mit diamanten dann bekommen wir
den matrix mord also dann bekommt ihr
die sachen die ich auch hier habe also
das sind ganz einfach so die kraft in
sachen ihr seht doch unten in der
beschreibung wieder wie immer den link
zu dem forum vor dem motto drin ist und
da könnt ihr dann euch einfach die
sachen angucken was das hier ist das
gehört nicht dazu da habe ich einfach so
eine andere einen anderen cobblestone
generator probiert und wartet auch ich
bedeutung dinge ins lot naja egal
jedenfalls wenn ich hier mit jetzt
rechtsklick mache dann läuft das alles
schon langsamer ihr seht dass ich
langsamer und auch wenn ich alt ems
wechsel ist das langsamer ihr seht das
recht wenn ich das wechsel ich könnte
jetzt mal einfach mich in den dingen
smart versetzen und mir mal ganz kurz
wenn schwert und vielleicht etwas zu
essen holen nokia geht wenn ich schlage
ist es auf jeden fall deutlich langsamer
ich versuche mal zu diesem schwein da
irgendwie hinzu kommen nicht das schaffe
also ist auch wenn ich springe das ist
alles langsamer wirklich ist bisher noch
ein wenig slow motion aber es geht noch
langsam erwartet guckt das ist alles
viel langsamer
wow
naja wenn man dann wieder damit rechts
weg macht dann läuft das ja alles ganz
normal und dann halt wieder rechtsweg
wieder nur langsam und so wieder normal
und jetzt nehmen wir mal einfach den
fest motion remote rottweil den find ich
ganz witzig hier drückt wartet ihr
drückt ihr drückt moment der braucht ein
bisschen bisher
funktioniert so jetzt funktioniert habe
ihr lauft halt doppelt so schnell oder
einmal so schnell ich glaube auf jeden
fall oft ziemlich schnell ihr seht da
schon
hüpfen und so sah alles noch ganz normal
also man hilft jetzt auch nicht
irgendwie weiter das heißt wenn ich
ganze sieht es ziemlich bekloppt aus
aber es läuft halt alles doppelt so
schnell wenn man guckt die schweine
laufen auch alle doppelt so schnell und
das wäre bestimmt ganz witzig mit ihnen
welchen schildern oder so dass dann das
glas einfach sich doppelt so schnell
bewegt oder auch jeher zum beispiel
fließt alles doppelt so schnell und es
halt ganz interessant sowie der
rechtsweg da drauf und alles ist wieder
ganz normal dann nehmen jetzt mal den
slow motion motto seht viel viel
ein schwein netz schlagen soll ich sehe
das ist richtig geil die moderne
irgendwie in einer großen höhle seitdem
ganz ganz viele monster sind da einfach
diese uhr mitnehmen und dann zur motion
mal eben machen und ihr könnt wirklich
da panschen und da und trifft quasi
jeden mod und vor allem auch wenn man
jetzt was ist guck mal
halo ist etwas ich hatte keine ahnung
ich bin dem creative mode ich glaube ich
kann jetzt auch nichts essen weil ich
ich mache mich mal kurz in den
festen mode
also da müsste ich doch theoretisch
gleich was von den dingen zu verlieren
oder von dem von den keulen vielleicht
mache ich das unbedingt zeigen wenn man
was ist das ist so geil
wartet mal
ich mach mich mal wieder hier so ganz
normal jetzt
so jetzt musste ich noch mal irgendwann
eine keule verlieren
irgendwie dauert dass man ein bisschen
länger moment wartet mal wartet mal
geschafft was geschafft hast
sie fangen schon langsam an zu zittern
bis hin
zum im moment ich habe es gleich ich
habe es gleich ich habe es gleich ich
habe es gleich
moment mal das ist wieder dieser vorfeld
vista damit man muss dann mal was zeigen
hier und da funktioniert hat alles
wieder nicht
so jetzt hier acht kommen jedenfalls er
gibt es da noch diese matrix dingens und
ratet mal das ist immer so ein bisschen
komisch mit diesen ganz ganz langsam
sachen
seht ihr schon das ist schon extrem
langsam ist es zwar noch nicht so
langsam wie super slow motion aber
wenn man hüpft und alles das ist schon
ziemlich komisch also ich glaube dieser
matrix mottos mehr dazu da dass wenn man
läuft und so halt alles noch relativ
normal ist aber wenn man springt ihr
seht das dann springt man doppelt so
weit und es ist halt total langsam und
auch wenn man schlägt jetzt irgendwie
moment warte kann man da überhaupt
doch man kann wartet so wenn man jetzt
schlägt alles richtig langsam guckt euch
das an
wie langsam der mit dem schwert schlägt
so ich würde jetzt echt gern so ein brot
essen aber das geht halt einfach nicht
weil ich einfach noch keine dingens
verloren habe aber egal downloaded euch
den mord selber probiert einfach aus es
gibt ja echt eine menge funktionen mit
dem motto so ich bin jetzt wieder im
normalen modus es gibt echt eine menge
funktion wenn man mal einfach dann ganz
schnell jetzt keine ahnung zurück zu
seinem dingens will dann drückt man
einfach diesen mortier so dass man ganz
schnell wieder da wo man hin will
einfach wieder drauf drücken ist wieder
normal so halt normale zeit luca ist
richtig richtig geiler mod ich werde ihn
auf jeden fall drin lassen wenn man
zwischendurch braucht man das bestimmt
mal irgendwann und ja dort euch den mod
link ist in der beschreibung musik ist
in der beschreibung facebook twitter der
beschreibung ich würde mich aber daumen
hoch freuen uns beim nächsten mal